[Music]
hi so just to make sure everyone's in
the right place
this is apt of 201 DevOps for
application developers I'm Asha I'm not
gonna have all the time after the talk
for questions I thought I would but
there's too much content to share with
you guys today so if you have questions
I encourage you to tweet them at me
I am the underscore [ __ ] miser which is
the spiky part at the end of a
stegosaurus and I have Wendy M's open if
you don't want to share your question
publicly I will try to get to them
tonight at some point I'm sorry I can't
do questions live so who's this talk for
so this talk is for folks like who have
an MVP you've got something that's super
cool you think it's gonna be the next
you know giant thing but you have no
idea how to get it to production in a
safe and stable way or maybe you're new
to GCP this event got a lot bigger this
year so I'm assuming that some of you
are new maybe maybe you're one of those
people who just wants a well-worn path
to follow when I was doing consulting we
had one way that we shipped most of our
web apps because we knew it we knew it
worked we knew how to do it right and so
we used it as much as we could
it was our well-worn path so I'm gonna
try to give you some ideas of some
well-worn paths on GCP and this talk is
especially for folks with minimal DevOps
experience who want to know just enough
that they can make cool things and make
them available for other people to use
them so what's this talk about the title
is decidedly vague this talk is about
production izing an application we're
gonna talk about your compute options on
GCP we're gonna talk about monitoring
application performance monitoring
specifically and then at the very end
that's going to be a recap we're gonna
give all the information again so that
you can see it twice and the AV team has
been really good about getting the talks
up on YouTube very very quickly so you
don't feel like you have to take notes
you will likely be able to see this
again at your own pace tomorrow and so
I'm gonna do something a little
different here every time I've gotten to
talk like this in the past I've been
like this is one of your compute options
this is what it's good at this is what
it's not good at but that didn't really
work for me with a narrative flow I
found it really boring and it didn't
actually help folks make good decisions
so I flipped that on its head for this
talk and the entire talk is going to be
based around question
I have seven questions that I think
everyone should ask themselves that
they're taking a nap to production and
they're not yes or no questions so
they're gonna make you think a little
bit I hope to do eventually do a blog
series about these questions because
there's a lot more that I'd like to
cover that I can't get to in the time
allowed so please bear with me if the
format doesn't work for your brain
hopefully for some of you it works
better than the standard format it works
really well for me so question number
one question number one is what are my
priorities if you're shipping something
you have priorities and priorities are
super important because everything in
the DevOps /sr your world is a trade off
the most sick here bug-free website is
one that doesn't exist and doesn't have
any users and was never published and
none of us want that so you're going to
have to have some downtime probably
maybe not a lot maybe only milliseconds
every year but you're gonna probably
have some downtime you're going to have
to make some sacrifices of how fast you
can move for robustness or maybe how
much you're willing to spend for how is
easy to use your application platform is
so you need to think about your
priorities
some examples of priorities is maybe
your very early stage and you're demoing
to potential investors okay there's a
different set of priorities for that
then if you're in beta testing or early
access or maybe even ready to go live
maybe your biggest priority is saving
money no shame no shame in saving money
I have worked at a start-up I've worked
at a startup that nearly ran out of
money I get it but you have to make sure
that you're aware of the fact that
that's your priorities you make
decisions with that in mind or maybe
your priority is robustness maybe you
are working on something where any
downtime is going to be a problem well
you're gonna make some decisions that
are based on that and they're going to
have other consequences elsewhere so
think really hard about what your
priorities are make sure you put them in
some sort of approximate stack ranked
order because those priorities are going
to influence your choices your compute
environment well some compute
environments are cheaper generally not
always true but frequently more managed
solutions are slightly more expensive
than less managed solutions but you're
sacrificing time maybe that's the right
trade-off for you if you need a lot of
robustness maybe you need a lot of
monitoring if you you know mostly don't
care maybe you don't if you're early
stage perhaps that's all you need maybe
you work in an industry that has
stringent audit logging requirements
well logging is going to be a priority
for you
maybe you don't write particularly good
code like me or you know you're jamming
this out at the last minute and so you
know there's going to be problems in
production so being able to debug or
trace and figure out what you did that's
making everything explode like my demo
downstairs dead yesterday is important
and maybe you need disaster recovery
this is something that nobody thinks of
until something goes wrong like there's
an outage and then you're like oh right
that's the thing that yeah I was
supposed to do that so make sure you
think about that up front a lot of
places don't need it especially early on
but you might get to a point where you
do so that was question one priorities
nothing actually technical there we're
gonna get slightly more technical as we
go on second question is what does my
load look like so I've worked at a bunch
of different places I've probably had
every job title that's common in tech at
this point and I had a company who I
worked at where we only got load during
the school day cuz we were an education
product so weekend's
no use midnight no use 9:00 to 3:00 lots
of use so we had different load
requirements than an app that has a
pretty steady use case or an app that
might have special work it does late at
night to do a bunch of computations are
a bunch of predictive modeling I worked
at this website once where we were doing
a release and we had done a write a
green blue type deployment we didn't
call it that back then because I've been
doing this for a while and we realized
that 9:00 a.m. on Saturdays was our
highest load we ever got during the week
and that's when we were trying to bring
the site back up and half of the cluster
was not actually sufficient to support
the entire load so we went down so that
was a good lesson for us to learn about
load also a good lesson for us to learn
about headspace but you need to think
about what your load looks like and this
is a question you should be asking
yourself on a somewhat regular basis
depending on how fast you're growing it
could be quarterly it could be yearly
but you need to be thinking about what
your load looks like because that's
going to influence your technology
choices so your load is going to
influence your choices I just said that
if you skate if you have a very variable
load so something that's a lot during
some periods none
during others sinusoidal you're gonna
probably want something that's
auto-scaling on GC P we have lots of
those
we have App Engine which is the one that
most people know been around for a
really long time ten years we have
google kubernetes engine which also auto
scales I'm using that for the one of the
installations downstairs in the showcase
floor
people don't frequently know that Google
compute engine will also auto scale you
can set up manage instance groups on
Google compute engine and say it should
be something between here and here and
it will auto scale those for you make
more as you need them take them down as
you don't and my new favorite is thing
ever Google Cloud functions also Auto
scales because it's functions as a
service and that's kind of what it does
it does units of work and you can do
lots of them are very few of them and
it's great if you have periods of time
where you don't want your website up or
your lotus-like probably doesn't need to
be up like if you're in that still
really early on investor stage where
you're only gonna give them access for a
couple days
scaling to zero is likely important so
if you're going to need to scale to zero
your choices are App Engine standard or
Google cloud functions lots of people
don't actually need to scale to zero but
if you need it it's a fantastic way to
save money so if money is a priority you
might consider that as well and then if
you're setting up auto scaling you need
to put bumpers you need to say this is
the minimum size this is the maximum
size and to do that you have to know
approximately how big your cluster might
need to get that's why we need to know
about how many users we're gonna have on
a regular basis the factor I've always
used in my professional career and I
don't know if this is endorsed by any
Google SR rating because I am NOT a
Google s re is 2x of the worst case
scenario now there is a case study on
our blog where 5x of the worst case
scenario was not actually sufficient so
no your use know how stuff's going to
grow I have had an app that went on a
morning TV show in the US and we way
over provision for that we actually
kicked it up to 4x just in case it went
really really well and the nice thing
about auto scaling stuff is you can say
ok just for this day cuz we know we're
gonna have this news article let's put
that top up limit really really high so
we can we'll be ok if something goes off
on but we don't have to pay for the
extra awesome
if things don't go so well so be aware
you need to again reevaluate this on a
regular basis you can set those bumpers
in appropriate places question 3 halfway
through there's 7 questions I don't
think I mentioned that um what skills do
I have this is what do you think deep
inside yourself and like what do I
actually know specifically languages and
frameworks um I'm a giant language dork
if you go to my Twitter profile or you
look at my conference bio I mentioned
prologue because I am a giant language
dork but at GCP I want to advocacy team
and one of my primary areas of advocacy
is brooby so you know very different if
I was gonna have to do a database backed
website right now I would pick up rails
I know it backwards forwards and inside
out I know that I can get something up
and running very very quickly but that's
not the best solution for a lot of
things doing WebSockets and rails until
very recently it was awful like truly
truly awful so I was gonna do WebSockets
I would have picked up something like
nodejs
um I also have been using node a lot
because I've been falling deeply in love
with cloud functions and called
functions supports node so think about
what you know if you're doing data
science python might be a real good
choice think about what you're
comfortable with also think about what
kinds of configurations are you used to
so I've been asking this question and
all the conference talks I've been doing
of late because it's confusing me deeply
who here has stood up a VM in a cloud or
like actually physically like something
they wracked like made a VM provision it
okay it's less than I expected but still
who's taking that VM to production ok so
if I ask that question 5 years ago it
would have been the vast majority of the
audience and now that we're in this
wonderful age of serverless and managed
services it's declining very steadily
over time no shame in having not done
that by the way but if you've never done
it and you don't want to learn it
probably compute engine is not your
choice you can also decide to learn
stuff you have to make sure your budget
extra time you have to make sure that
you have resources available meetups
whatever to learn things make sure
you're making that choice on purpose
I've been helping a number of folks over
the last two years who are like everyone
says I should use containers and unlike
containers are awesome and they're like
this is my first web application I don't
notice that traces and unlike containers
are not your good choice right now let's
do something else because you shouldn't
be using containers unless you're
comfortable enough with your stack that
you can deal with the fact the container
adds an extra layer of indirection that
makes everything just slightly harder if
you're debugging application code makes
a lot of stuff easier it's a good way to
make sure you're getting the most bang
for your buck out of your infrastructure
but it makes some things harder and you
should make sure you go into that with
your eyes open just cuz everyone else's
containers are awesome does not mean
containers are awesome for you just
because everyone else says serverless it
awesome does not mean that serverless is
awesome for you if you went to my
colleague brian Dorsey's talk about
where do I run my stuff earlier there
was a giant slide that said it depends
and that's because it depends there is
not one best way that's the thesis of
this talk that's what we're gonna be
talking about the entire time so we have
some language restrictions with our
compute offerings um hey wish we didn't
because my language is not particularly
well represented but we are adding more
languages and more support all the time
and it is getting better it's so much
better than it was three and a half
years ago when I started at GCP so
Google had functions runs note more
languages are coming soon I cannot
define what soon is I am sorry
and when they come soon they will be in
beta and I'm here to tell you right now
you should not use beta products in
production please don't it's a really
bad idea
don't feel like I should have to say
that people do it all the time because
they're super excited and then it loads
or we massively change the interface or
something so don't use beta products in
production pretty please we have App
Engine standard which supports Java
Python go and note is now in beta so
again don't use beta products in
production please but hopefully we'll be
going G a relatively soon
App Engine standard is amazing but there
are some restrictions on the libraries
that you can use and both Google Cloud
functions and app engines Dadar don't
let you write to disk it's becoming less
of an issue recently but for a long time
people were like well I have to write to
disk and like well you don't have to but
writing to disk is important don't use
those products if you're writing to disk
and you're doing something that's based
on HTTP you might want to rethink that
because at the end of the day HTTP is in
fact stateless and writing to disk is
preserving state so you know make sure
that you've reconciled those
contradictions in your head
App Engine flex this is our yes we can
run containers any container you want in
a managed fashion we support all of our
official languages all seven of them
let's see if I could name the seven
dwarves Java Python go pH P node dot net
and Ruby but you can also run anything
you can run in a container on this last
year at this event one of my colleagues
demand Perl in a container as part of
his talk so really truly on App Engine
flex we can run anything as long as he
can put it in a container google
kubernetes engine yes you can run
anything there if you can run it in a
container and Google compute engine if
you can run it on your lap you can run
it on compute engine mostly almost
always and there's probably some things
you can do on compute engine that you
can't do on your lap because your lappy
you know fits in your bag and you can
make a really big machine on compute
engine so fourth question what is the
happy path who's heard the term happy
path before it's one of my favorites so
happy path is the thing that you want
people to be doing on your website so if
you sell stuff that's the path where you
sell them things because that's how you
make money and that's how your website
keeps going if you've got some sort of
social media thing you probably want
people to log in and like view a feed
and talk to their friends the happy path
if you've heard the 8020 rule is the
eighty case this is the stuff that goes
on most of the time your I forgot my
password link is not the happy path it's
important but it is not the happy path
it's not where people are spending most
of their time and once you know what
your happy path is you need to
instrument the heck out of it
first thing minimum bar you should have
uptime checks you should make sure that
you know if the site goes down because
if you don't you're gonna get angry
customers or angry marketing folks don't
do that
stackdriver monitoring has uptime checks
down at the disruption detector we're
showing that you can just see your
uptime checks in real time with latency
from all over the globe
uptime checks are awesome but they're
boring the next thing you should do is
you should monitor the performance of
the happy path this is where people are
going to spend most of their time so
this is the stuff that needs to be fast
and consistent we have stock driver a
p.m. which is stock driver application
performance monitoring if you've never
heard the APM acronym before my favorite
part about a stock driver trace its
distributed tracing it works across
micro-services and it gives you a nice
visual time
representation of what's going on if
you're out I've been doing this long
enough that I actually wrote one of
these out on graph paper with crayons at
one of my previous jobs to prove that we
were fine we didn't need more servers
but it's so much better when the
computer draws the graphic for you I
really liked race because it helps me
see things like N+ 1 query errors this
is a really common error that you see in
things like Django and rails where you
have a loop and inside the loop you're
doing a query to get a single row so
every time you go through that loop you
do a query and it's much more
performance you do the query ahead of
time pull back all the data and then
iterate through it because queries have
i/o implications and they take longer
and I have written apps sorry on Google
cloud platform that have this and in
trace it's like really obvious because
it's my sequel it's cloud sequel cloud
sequel cloud sequel oh I should not do
that
we also Spector of a profiler it's
relatively new everyone who's using it
loves it it's another way to see
potential performance problems in your
application metrics so when I worked at
the startup we actually had an office we
had a cash register sound that played in
the office every time we made a sale we
were new it was exciting and every time
we had to do a refund we played this on
backwards
that was a metric there are all kinds of
metrics maybe it's simultaneous users or
a number of successful logins or a
number of times someone has gone through
your checkout path there's all sorts of
metrics depending on your app there's
ones that are interesting or not to you
nice thing about stackdriver is that you
can take those metrics out of your logs
because there's a lot of stuff you can't
actually pull out of system data but
it's all over the logs and you can make
those log messages show up in aggregated
form averages means counts in your
dashboards as metrics and then you can
do alerts on them so that's super cool
it's one of my favorite things about
stackdriver
right now and then there's SLA
monitoring we talked about it a bit in
one of the keynotes there's one other
talks about it we have a blog post we
published last week on this to do us all
a monitor incorrectly you need to know
what your SLA is so if you have a team
you should sit down with your team you
should talk about your happy path and
you talk about what is a reasonable
amount of time that those requests
should be taking this is a very
uncomfortable conversation I recommend
starting with the data you already have
and decide is this okay if it's okay you
should just make sure that you know if
it gets worse
if it's not okay well you need to put
stuff in your work queue to fix it and
then you should make sure that you know
if you're getting worse one of the
places I worked we just had a stoplight
we had five requests that were the thing
they made up 98% of our traffic and we
had a stoplight because we knew we
wanted the 95 percent case on all of
those to be within a certain range and
if it went outside the stop light turned
red and that was bad question five so
what are the rough spots of your
application so some of you are thinking
I don't write code that has rough spots
and I'm thinking awesome can I be you
because I write code that has rough
spots all the time there are going to be
spots for you didn't get as much QA
coverage maybe it was really hard to
test it maybe it's a third party
integration maybe you hate all tomato
testing frameworks and you know that you
just didn't get to maybe there's that
one person on your team who's like my
code is perfect I shouldn't have to test
I'm gonna fall I'm not gonna follow the
rules great we all have rough spots
Google has rough spots
everyone has rough spots just know what
they are because you want to treat them
differently when you're going to
production you want to instrument them
so one of the things I'm very passionate
about there's a couple things in this
talk but this is one of my favorites is
you should know what their rates of five
xx + 4 xx errors are compared to your
200s and your 300s here's why you should
know that I have found very many three
minis not correct English I have found a
lot of production blogs you're using
this my two favorites are I was working
in a company and marketing sent out a
marketing email with a deep link to the
website problem is we hadn't implemented
that deep link yet so all of a sudden
there 404 rates spiked we had
instrumentation on it we had alerts on
and we're like something is not quite
right here let's go fix that and we were
able to really quickly shove a redirect
in to make it so that all those people
had received that marketing message
after the first you know 50 or so got to
the right place they didn't just see a
404 and think well those guys are dumb
another story I was working in
consulting and we were doing a project
for a company and we had just brought it
online for the first time and someone
and our contact of the company hadn't
told the IT department that we were
doing this so the IT guy or gal sees a
thing on the network that hadn't done
before so they do the logical thing and
they start probing it trying to figure
out if it's secure right
make sense and we're sitting there going
what are people doing to our application
because the 404 is the 500s all the
errors start spiking through the roof
and so we do the exact right thing you
should do when someone's trying to find
vulnerabilities in your website which is
we blocked that IP address and then we
get a call saying why did you guys block
the IT departments IP address um
because they were doing mean things to
our application but then we were able to
figure out a time when they could do the
security scan when we knew that they
were doing the security scan and it
wasn't gonna affect development so you
know communication but if that had been
someone from the widen big wide scary
internet blocking their IP address would
have been the right thing to do and we
only knew about it because we had this
kind of monitoring in place
trace and debugger to features in
stackdriver
I've talked a little bit about trace
again it will help you find your errors
debugger is the coolest thing we have I
am so stoked about it if you haven't
played with its doctor ever debugger is
live application for debugging in
production you install an agent it sits
in the background those are not a lot of
latency or any latency depending on the
language and does nothing and then
you're like how the heck did that person
get into that section of the if I don't
know that's not supposed to happen and
you're like greats doctor every debugger
you go into the UI you can either run it
completely locally or you can hook your
cloud repo up to it
it shows you your code you hit a little
button you're like tell me what the
state of the application is when someone
gets here and an application a quest
goes through maybe from you maybe from a
customer and what we do is we capture
the call stack all the local variables
all the information that you probably
need to debug it and we print it out for
you and then we let the request to
finish we don't give you step through
debugging because that would be a
horrible experience for whoever is on
the other end of that request but we do
give you a good sized watch window and a
set of information about it and a future
we added in the last couple months maybe
year is we have a very small logging
language that you can add arbitrary log
lines to an application that is running
in production and the reason this is
cool is you don't have to redeploy you
can do it all live you can do it all in
the UI you don't actually have to push
new code and for anyone who's had to
instrument a bunch of code and then push
it and then had all of those log lines
or whatever effect you're all
requests this is magic and I'm gonna
take a drink of water and some of you
should just think about what we had to
do to make that work for compiled
languages like Java and go because it's
gross like the day I'm like wait wait we
have this for Java how did we do that
and then they told me and I'm like
that's gross and a lot of these a lot of
the libraries that do this are actually
open source you can go look and see how
we do it like for Ruby this was not
scary to me of course we rewrote classes
at runtime we do that stuff it's fine
and the other thing you should do on
your rough bits is you should make sure
that you shorten your release cycle as
much as possible
I've been debugging a lot of stuff the
last few weeks and if I have to wait 15
minutes to figure out if my change
worked it is a bad day for me so we
talked about cloud build in one of the
keynotes
it is my new favorite is thing ever
you're like here's a bunch of steps go
do that on really big machines Google
and then put the stuff that you build or
make somewhere where I can grab it later
that's on your network so it's on the
same network as my production hardware
so I don't have to deal with latency
it's fantastic there's a limited set of
stuff that's already pre-configured for
cloud build but watch this space who's
going to be more and more templates and
examples coming from both the community
and from Google over the next several
months maybe years I work on the
languages efforts specifically an
advocacy and a bunch of those are trying
to figure out what the right templates
to give our language communities are app
engine standard has a relatively short
release cycle you're like please make
this new you code go here that's great
use that and plug functions again I said
it's one of my new favorite things I
have been debugging some really gross
cloud functions because I'm not
particularly good JavaScript developer
and the fact that I can edit it in the
UI hit the yeah I try that button and it
spins for you know a minute maybe T
maybe only 30 seconds and then there's a
tab next to it that says test and I
click that and it tries the function and
then the logs for that request spit out
underneath it it's great I can iterate
doing several can probably do 5 to 10
different try attempts in an hour maybe
even more it's fantastic
ok so now question 6 helpful tolerant mi
so this is the one that makes everyone
really really nervous and really really
not ok with the fact that I'm saying
this
I'm going to tell you right now that you
have to accept that sometimes things are
going to go wrong maybe it's not your
fault
maybe a shark bit through the undersea
cable there is a story about that
happening you can go find it on the
internet but things things that are bad
are going to happen so you have to
acknowledge things that are bad are
going to happen you have to decide what
you're willing to accept if you've been
to any of the sre talks you've probably
heard about the idea of error budgets I
like error budgets error budgets are
fantastic now maybe you work on an
application that keeps airplanes flying
and keeps people alive awesome you're
amazing you're your risk tolerance is
going to be lower than mine I make
websites it's fine if they go down for a
little while nobody's going to die so
think about what your fault tolerance is
maybe you can deal with an arbitrary or
you know a reasonable amount of down
time outside of business hours but you
really need to stay up during business
hours or maybe 15 minutes a month is all
you can offer but you need to know that
so you can make the right decisions
about how much capacity you need to
provision how much you need to monitor
and all that once you know how fault
tolerant you are you can work backwards
and figure out what you should be
monitoring you should monitor as
thoroughly as you need to to make sure
that you have achieved your
fault-tolerance goals so if you're if
you're not particularly worried uptime
is probably enough for you
but if performance is important to you
your fault tolerance if you need to know
that everything is working across data
centers if you need to know you know
latency on things monitor the stuff
monitor the stuff that can't fail or
monitor the stuff where you need to talk
to someone if it does fail if you don't
take anything else from this talk please
take the next two points and like write
them millions of times until you get it
don't wake yourself up if you can't do
anything about it
alerts must be actionable my wonderful
story about this was I carried the pager
for a company for a couple years and one
night at like 2:00 a.m. the pager goes
off and you know heartbeat goes up and
the alert was the production disk on one
of the five production servers is an 86%
full okay and I go look at the alert
history and I'm like oh five days ago is
85% full I don't have to do anything
about that it - and there is nothing
interesting happening
we could wait several more weeks and it
would be fine so I should not have
gotten woken up for that alert that is
an example of a battle dirt it was also
alert that I configured so that's my own
own fault but make sure that if you're
alerting on something that there easier
there's something technological that you
can do to fix it or there is someone
that you need to be either be telling
that something is going wrong or
apologizing to that is also in action
but if there's nothing that you would do
in the middle of the night if this went
off if it can wait till the next morning
alert in an appropriate format also
alert on what needs to work if you're ok
with you know your forgotten password
link not working for a couple hours that
should not set your pages off focus on
the stuff that's really important to
work and please ignore the rest because
pager fatigue is totally a thing and
it's horrible when you get it and it
makes everyone ignore everything that's
going on and something bad happens and
everyone freaks out it's just it's no
don't please don't your life will be
better if you don't I also like what I'm
setting up a site have two dashboards I
have a dashboard for my happy path my
critical path and then I have another
dashboard that is the entire system
holistically the reason I have this if
someone comes running over to my desk
and tells me that everything is on fire
and I'm like oh that is very interesting
and then I look up at my two dashboards
and if the happy path dashboard is all
red and scary yes everything is on fire
and I should probably work on that right
now but if the holistic dashboard is red
and scary but the happy path is not red
and scary I probably have a little bit
of time before stuff goes really
sideways so I can take a deep breath and
gather my thoughts and get to a place
where I can actually deal with this in
an appropriate fashion I find it really
helps for me to separate is everything
on fire or is only the really important
stuff on fire or as you know the thing
that's on fire
interesting I like when stuff breaks
it's cool and not so but not so urgent
so I'm gonna talk about disaster
recovery I'm not gonna give you a ton of
information on this go read stuff um I'm
going to tell you that the LVS Ares I
know would tell you you should be in
multiple regions or zones pretty please
it's better for you it's better for
everyone please make sure that you can
deploy in multiple regions or zones you
don't have to have them both live if you
don't deploy in well through multiple
zone make sure that you can deploy to a
new region or zone relatively quickly if
being up relatively quickly is important
Google had an outage last week it was a
global outage but lots of other cloud
providers including us have had regional
outages before a good way to protect
yourself against those is to be in
multiple regions or zones it's also if
dun dun C is really important to you for
busting this is really important to you
pick one of the options that
self-healing most of our things can be
self-healing if you configure them to be
that way I love kubernetes because like
I can't just like delete VMs underneath
and it's like oh there's a VM that is
deleted let me please create a new one
it's just chill about it's great I also
if you're going to do multiple regions
one of my biggest pet peeves about other
systems that I've used is that you can
only see one region at a time on your
screen I really like the GCP this is
like my only marketing thing here I
really like the GCP shows you everything
you saw in the keynote on Tuesday when
they showed the kubernetes on-prem that
you could see two different clusters at
the same time in different regions I
can't tell you the number of times I
have lost a VM because I created it in a
region that I'm not currently looking at
in other providers and then disaster
recovery is complete ly unless you
practice it I deleted a production
database at midnight and the only reason
that I did not completely freak out and
lose my brain was that I had practiced
restoring a backup on my local machine
multiple times I'd done it on staging
machine so I took a deep breath got
myself a glass of tea and started the
restore and then emailed my boss and
said sorry we're gonna be out for a
while I should have it back up but you
know one one maybe two so the last thing
I have on my list of questions and this
is the one that everyone messes up where
are my secrets everyone's got secrets
secrets might be things like service
account keys it may be API keys for
third-party services and the big one is
user info hi I am likely to be a user of
at least one of your guys's products at
one point please don't leak my data I
would very much appreciate that so where
does Secrets end up secrets end up all
sorts of awesome places secrets end up
in source control I have checked in a
GCP service account key before I yes
once you have done that you need to
provision a new key and delete that and
never
use it again you have just shared it
with the entire Internet it's a password
we don't share those secrets frequently
end up on development and build servers
and you're like well that's ok except I
worked at a company where we had one of
our dev boxes stolen someone's stole it
on the subway or something and if we had
had any user info or any API keys on
that machine they would have been
immediately compromised so try not to
let secrets get on dev boxes is a really
bad idea
the one that happens a lot a lot a lot a
lot and has happened recently to a
relatively large tech company is that
secrets end up in logs frequently these
is personal information so think about
it this way someone submits a form do
you log the post body a lot of
frameworks and applications do you by
default anything in that post body is
now likely in plain text in your logs so
my password my credit card you know my
address all of that may have just been
dumped to your logs no we don't do that
I have done it I felt very guilty about
it and we fixed it within an hour it was
a long time ago like 15 years ago the
same thing with alerts if you have a 500
error do you take a whole entire
snapshot of the request and then throw
that in the alert that you're sending
out to the person on call again that's
probably got some stuff in it that you
shouldn't be doing that with because if
you're sending it out to an alerting
system you're automatically sharing all
that info with whatever the alerting
system is think about it I'm not saying
you shouldn't do it but make sure you're
doing it consciously email I worked at a
company where we emailed every piece of
user feedback to every employee at the
company no that's a bad idea as well we
ended up running it through an
anonymizer and then doing it which was
and it was actually quite awesome
because some of the feedback was great
and then databases you're like well of
course personal information ends up in
databases please see my comments about
dev boxes getting stolen if you let
people install a production copy on
their local machine make sure that
everything in there is anonymized
ideally you would have a separate
database of test info that they could
use for testing so how do you protect
your secrets there's some stuff that you
just have to do in your engineering
practices they have to be done in the
application layer I'm sorry we don't
have magic stuff for that yet I'm sure
they will come up with something soon
they seem to come up with magic stuff
all the time but we do
the metadata metadata service and
kubernetes secrets api's metadata
service is one of my favorite things
about UCP I can say here put this SSH
key on all of my boxes oh that guy left
tape that SSH key off of all of my boxes
and I don't have to reprovision machines
especially when I was consulting we were
constantly for visioning machines as
people cycled on and off the project you
can also use you can use the CLI I like
using the web interface because I'm lazy
kubernetes secrets is a little confusing
there's a lot of people who have
opinions about it but I've talked to
enough of those people now that I
actually believe the way they're doing
it is good you there's a couple ways to
do it the way I like doing it is you set
up some secrets and then you can access
those there's different ways that you
get access to that information you can
do environment variables or you can also
have them mounted as a file system that
you can then pull from as part of your
container there's a couple ways to do it
it's great just take a deep breath if
you're like this is the weirdest way to
do this they've thought about it a lot
this is one of the few times I will say
give them a shot you don't have to agree
but at least try it
so I told you we were gonna have a
review at the end compute cloud
functions you can use javascript
javascript is awesome python is coming
soon it scales from zero to lots and
lots and lots I believe that as a
technical term I really like the speedy
deployment cycle on this one and if you
can get into the small functions lots of
people working on small pieces thing
it's great some people can't get their
heads around it it took me a while but I
think I'm there now compute engine it's
a VM it can run stuff you run on a
computer you can make it whatever size
and shape you want we have sliders for
that if you're gonna do this
checkout managed instance groups they
have health checks that you can use if
you use the health check so you can get
self-healing and you can also get auto
scaling and so you get all the kind of
niceties that people talk about if some
of the managed services but you just
have it on a p.m. VMs are familiar to
many of us we know how to make a VM work
it's awesome and it's cheaper but it
might need more of your time to handle
it or you know set up set up
provisioning scripts and something like
puppet chef or ansible App Engine we
have two flavors standard and flexible
it's really easy to fly you type g-cloud
app deploy if it's one of the languages
we know and we say it looks like you're
running blah would you like us to write
a configuration file for that it
supports all languages in some form and
it's
anything you can run in a container on
flex app engine standard scales down to
zero so anything that runs on App Engine
standards you can scale down to zero but
it has restrictions on what libraries
you can use logging error reporting and
basic monitoring come by default with
App Engine standard and they're very
easy to set up for App Engine flex and
it doesn't load balancing and networking
for you my least favorite part of
running on VMs is setting up networking
and so if someone else does that that's
great
kubernetes engine it runs containers I'm
supposed to have a picture of a
container ship or something on this side
but it does auto scaling and
self-healing it can't scale down to zero
but it can scale down to not very much
there are no restrictions on what you
can run as long as you can put it in a
container and it does the load balancing
and networking for you so I actually end
up burning a lot of stuff in kubernetes
engine because I get to one whatever I
want in whatever way I want and the
service discovery for me and I don't
have to set up load balancing and
networking it's fantastic stackdriver
the other main thing I talked about
today this is our operations monitoring
logging debugging it helps you make
stuff better and know what's going on
platform stock driver monitoring
alerting me of any different means you
can get emails you can get you know
something dumped into pager duty or into
one of your team chat apps you can set
up custom dashboards you have serve
system level monitoring so how much CPU
am i using how many bytes are going over
the wire but also application level
monitoring what's my ratio of errors
what's my average latency
what's the latency of 94 the 95 percent
case because we all know that if you
just look at the mean that one request
that took five minutes is just going to
break everything
it's multi-cloud you can use it on AWS
and GCP and for a lot of the features
you can actually use that on primer
anywhere you can run your stuff if you
install the libraries now if you're
gonna do this remember alerts should be
actionable and you should probably set
up something that vaguely looks like a
system over abuse you can quickly know
what the heck is going on doctor for
logging log aggregation you can search
stuff pretty good query language you can
export to files or you can export to
bigquery which is really super crazy
powerful you can feed the logs into
metrics and monitoring I talked about
that earlier
again multi-cloud use our libraries you
can also use it on przemek
use our library's tips handle your
secrets with care please don't dump
secrets to logs unless you can control
access to those very very well trace
this is the tracing through
micro-services thing this lets you kind
of see the timeline of what's going on
in your application it also has cool
features like period over period
performance so someone's like the
website is slower this week and you can
say no I can impose a latency graph over
top from last week in this week and the
answer to that is no or you can say yeah
sorry about that I'll fix it you can
also debug bottlenecks and timeouts
quickly for some sets of errors we may
actually predict what the problem is and
say hey you might consider adding an
index here but you need to instrument
your app unless you're running on App
Engine standard and there's a the
recommended agents going to be different
depending on your language for some
we're using open census for some we're
using stackdriver to trace agents I
believe we're moving in the direction of
open census for everything stackdriver
debugger this is the live production
debugging
please go try this no one believes me
and it is amazing but again you need to
instrument your app with the agent a lot
of people get a little twitchy about
they're like well why should I have this
running in the background should have it
running in the background so that when
something goes wrong you don't have to
do another release cycle did you book it
and it's doctor error reporting is crash
aggregation it something broke it groups
all the stuff that's vaguely similar it
takes representative traces it can link
you to the logs it can link to your bug
tracker so you can kind of say you can
start from something is wrong and then
look at all the other tools that are all
linked together to debug it if you've
ever had to assemble a performance
monitoring regular monitoring log
aggregation tool from a bunch of
different toolkits having everything
talk to each other is really really nice
and saves a lot of time it has alert
back off built in so if you do something
really stupid and you're getting a lot
of alerts you won't actually have your
pocket explode on you every time someone
hits the path that's broken and it's
automatically set up for App Engine
standard it's really easy to set up for
App Engine flex you just grab the
library and you shove it in your app I
stuck to her profiler people were just
super into this it helps you improve
code performance so that's probably why
they're in different it's also really
easy to use and uses flame graphs that
people are used to we haven't for Java
go and node right now
I would assume more is coming I don't I
can't actually give you a timeline on
that and that's what I have thank you
for coming I know it's the end of the
second day and this is a giant crazy
conference and very overwhelming I
appreciate your time again I'm Asha I'm
on the application I'm on the
application development advocacy team so
I am NOT an ops person but I'm happy to
answer any of your questions you can
email me at [ __ ] oh my sir I just spelled
exactly how it sounds at google.com or
you can tweet at me the underscore
Thacker my sir and I have a couple
minutes at the end after I'm talking to
hand out some stickers to people that I
actually have an appointment very
shortly so thank you very much I
appreciate your attention
[Applause]
[Music]